if you stand in Britain with a Hamas
flag you should not be allowed to be
free in Britain here is Douglas Murray
once again on what you have to do with
these people who are who are openly
calling for genocide they are fine with
terrorist attacks and they are brazenly
expressing that on the Streets of London
I came back to London the other night
and I hear the residue of the people
outside the Israeli Embassy these people
were not protesting against Israeli
countermeasures they hadn't even had any
countermeasures they were protesting
because Jews by the hundreds had been
slaughtered in Israel and they wanted to
wound us
more well they might
try but we should not accept that with
equinity I've written in The Spectator
tomorrow a demand on the Prime Minister
and the Home Secretary that supporters
of hamaz in the UK must be treated in
exactly the same way as supporters of
Isis were this
some people thought that the claim that
Hamas was Isis was a rhetorical claim we
know since Saturday if we didn't know
before it is not rhetoric it is real if
you stand in Britain with a Hamas flag
you should not be allowed to be free in
Britain you should be arrested have your
citizenship withdrawn your passport
withdrawn you should be deported you
should be sent to the Gaza and try your
luck
there but you should not be given the
right to insult and to taunt Jews after
the death of Jews it's intolerable and
we should not tolerate it but I'll go a
step further and then we're going to
show you some video of what's going on
in London it's not it's not that you
just Jews this isn't just Jews the
average Brit who once had a country that
was British and believed in Law and
Order and was a a flourishing
thriving nation has been largely
demolished